- See your new movie,
I loved the original "Sonic the Hedgehog,"
was played so much in our
house, this one will as well.
So thank you for that, for a new movie.
(chuckling)
But the new movie, so what's it about?
- Well, we get to see Sonic
in a new world playing
and doing the things that we saw before,
but it's bigger, better, and faster.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- My character is Rachel
and my sister is Maddie
played by the incredible Tika Sumpter.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And my fiance is Shemar Moore.
(audience applauding)
- I know I'm interviewing him
for the movie as well, yeah.
- I may or may not have
had a calendar of him
when I was 16 on my wall.
(audience laughing)
- Dreams do come true.
- They do.
They really, really do.
And so when the director
called me and he was just like,
"We'd love to have you
back for the second movie."
"How do you feel about
playing opposite Shemar Moore?
Then there was a Natasha size
hole in my wall where I ran.
(audience laughing)
He's like, we're not shooting just yet.
And then I ran back home and I was like,
"Alright cool."
- [Kelly] I'm ready.
- I'm ready, let's do it.
- You are so funny in the first one.
So I just, literally I love
when people make films like this
that are for kids and adults.
- [Natasha] Yeah.
- We all enjoy it at the same time.
- It's for everybody.
- It's really cool of y'all to do for us.
(Natasha laughing)
Cause some of them aren't for adults,
and you're like, "Oh my gosh," yeah.